I'm going to talk today about
topological data analysis and what we do
at iOS D so I have kind of two goals
here that for this talk so first I want
to show how TDA is a framework for data
analysis or machine learning sort of if
you think of machine learning just as
large-scale data analysis and and then I
want to demonstrate specifically how a
Asli uses uses TDA
to help companies and so at the end of
the talk I'd like to show you some of
the actual use case some actual use
cases from some of our clients and so
TDA encompasses a number of things and
I'm really just going to talk about the
part of TDA that I as d-does so there
are other things that I'm not going to
talk about persistent homology sensor
networks with sheaves things like that
but that's fine okay so what we want to
do is extract meaning from complex data
so we want to get insights from our data
we want to make our data useful and I
say complex because well data is complex
because it's big meanings there's a lot
of it so that's one way data is complex
and we deal with some of that at a Oz D
but we also deal with a lot of data
that's complex because it's feature-rich
so if you think of something like
genetic data you could have snip data
you could have 500,000 columns in the
data set and there's complicated
interdependencies among those columns
among gene expression levels about among
you know mutations among all kinds of
things and so I don't want to think of
the data problem as just being one of
volume I want to think of complexity and
complexity can come volume it can come
can come from other other problems as
well so or of course both right can
always have both so
the way I see the problem with in both
cases is that there's a lot happening in
your data so a metaphor that I like to
think about is that of a room you walk
into a room full of people and when you
walk in it's just white noise right
there's all these different
conversations happening and what you
want to do is find those conversations
that are relevant to you or in some way
summarize the conversations in the room
so that's that's the the problem with
with big data and with complexity are
the number of stories going going on and
what we want to do is create summaries
that are useful to us so TDA
on this kind of high level this
metaphorical level is the tool that's
going to summarize out the irrelevant
stories to get at something interesting
and in a certain sense I mean this in a
kind of technical way because what we do
is actually we we summarize the geometry
and and we do that in a rigorous way so
the metaphor has is reasonably deep ok
so this here is kind of our guiding
principle at I Aziz the data has shape
and shape has meaning that's the
motivation for everything we do that's
that's how we try and approach our
problems is what what is the shape of
our data how do I extract the shape of
the data what is the shape of the data
tell me so um I'm going to focus on the
second half of this and not get too much
into exactly what shape means I want to
talk about extracting meaning from shape
okay but first well let's just just um
since I've gotten this question before
well what is shape let's just spend a
slide to describing what shape is so I
describe shape is like my one my one
sentence that that that that I used to
describe shape is that shape is the
global realization of local constraints
so locally there's in your data locally
in the space you're looking at the sub
constraints
/ what can happen right but those local
that those local constraints is sort of
doesn't really create shape shape is
what happens when you take the big
picture of all those constraints right
if you look at a circle locally it's
very flat it looks like a line but it's
you know bending ever so slightly when
you take that global picture you get the
circle and that's the shape that's the
shape of your data so for a given
problem
shape is determined by your choice of
features sensors that you're pulling
data from columns in your data if you're
thinking of tabular data as properties
to measure and then a metric on those
features so that metric is the summary
of what those local constraints are so
that's one way to define shape but there
are more relaxed notions of shape and
the techniques I'm going to describe to
you today are going to work with those
other more relaxed notions so everything
I'll probably say this a couple more
times everything I say will work for
essentially abstract topological spaces
where you have some open covering of the
space so you have a set of open sets
that cover cover the space but to stay
concrete everything I say will be done
with rows and columns the rows are your
data points the columns are your
features there'll be a kind of metric
lurking in the background and and will
just move and then stay in that sort of
concrete more familiar the world so the
goal this is just rephrasing what I said
earlier it's to understand or summarize
the shape and and part of that that's
that's really important for TDA which is
what I think distinguishes it from a lot
of other techniques is that we have no
preconceived notions of what the shape
should be so we're not doing any kind of
like manifold fitting or linear fitting
or anything like that we really trying
to shoe the preconceived notions of what
our data looks like
okay so I'm going to kind of step into
the TDA
and a couple steps so first I'm going to
start in math world so we're not indeed
a world yet so what do I mean by math
well I'm going to draw the data as a
smooth manifold so it's just going to be
a smooth shape and when I say function
or lens you should think something
smooth continuous nice in you know
whatever class of functions you you want
to consider so that's because that's
going to give you the right intuition
and kind of internal mental picture but
we don't need any of these assumptions
when we're actually in data world doing
the analysis all the things that I'll
describe will go through without
modification okay and maybe even more
importantly is that in the real world
data is never really sampled from a
smooth manifold or I should say there
are certain engineering problems that
are very rigidly constrained where data
might be sampled from a smooth manifold
or from a you know maybe just the
locally smooth or you know stratified
space or something but in general real
data is never like this it's kind of
crazy and wild and we should keep that
in mind okay so here's our our our data
and I've drawn here it's an inverted
pair of pants and when I produce here
I'm going to now kind of flesh out this
picture and I'm going to produce show
you how we make topological summaries
from the data but you should remember
that you never actually get to see you
data and and the reason I'm drawing it
as this nice two dimensional manifold is
so that you can concretely see exactly
what is the thing that I'm summarizing
what is the topology what have I lost
what am I saying right will you'll be
able to see it all exactly but in
reality you never get to see it so you
should put kind of a big black box over
the data okay so here's how we start we
start with a continuous function f and
and
this function f at a Osby we call the
lens on your data and I'll probably
switch back and forth between saying
lens and saying function and you just
have to have to bear with me I apologize
I've been sort of it doctrine Aidid into
the corporate language but it's just
it's just a function and you should
consider it a smooth function so here's
what we do we take a point P and here
the way I've drawn it I'm thinking of
this function is just the height
function on this data so I take a point
P in the range of the function I look at
the inverse image of P so that's this
circle here I take that inverse image
and I'm going to draw a point on the far
right here for every connected component
of the inverse image so the way I drew
this here there's just one connected
component there's just a circle in the
inverse image so I drew a point on the
far right ok so let's look at the point
Q now we have two circles in the inverse
image so there's two connected
components so I'm going to draw two
points and that's it that's all we're
going to do and I just go through all
the points now systematically do that I
get this Y so this is this is a summary
of the data space so the data space
started off as this pair of pants that
has this hollow cavity and with this
function the summary I have produced is
this y what if I captured I've captured
the legs on the pair of pants what if I
lost well I've lost all the holes this
the circles right with this function so
that's one choice the function well now
I'm going to look at another function to
show you how other functions will
extract other summaries from the data so
this function is just this function that
goes down G so P look at the inverse
image of P it's this right this left
edge and so I'm just going to draw a
point for that left edge moving slightly
to the right I have
two pieces in the inverse image there's
this front line in this back line so
continuing on like that I get a circle
until I reach this middle point here
where again the inverse image of a point
in the middle it's going to the saddle
point here it's connected so I just get
over that image a line and then on the
other side by symmetry I'm going to have
a circle again so here's my second
function and this is my second summary
which is I've captured now something
completely different about my data I've
captured the the fact that there are two
legs there are two leg holes so
different functions are creating
different summaries this I mean this is
it this is what we do and it's
surprisingly useful and powerful and
yeah so I guess all the best ideas are
really simple I think that that's fair
to say ok so we have the the two holes
for the legs and we have the leg leg
structure
okay so since this is a course I thought
I'd have an exercise for everyone which
is what happens if I use both lenses at
the same time so both functions G and F
I wrote G and F and not F and G because
G was the one with the X direction and F
was the one with the Y direction so what
happens if I use both functions at the
same time so the image now is two demint
the range is two-dimensional and I want
to take a point P in the range I want to
take the inverse image of P take the
connected components of the inverse
image of P and then let P range over the
whole range so I'll just give everyone a
minute to think about that if you if you
solve it you should raise your hand and
tell us the answer if you know the
answer which I know there are some
ringers in the crowd you may not answer
and you take us okay it can be hard to
do it in your head so let's just step
through how to do this so it's an
exercise I guess only if you stop and do
it so P has the inverse image of P from
F F inverse P is the circle it's right
in the middle so the inverse image from
G is that saddl loop and I take the
intersection of both of those to get the
inverse image under both G and F
simultaneously so the inverse image of
of P under this combined map consists of
just two points so when I draw now write
those two points are two connected
pieces so that means in the output step
I would draw two points right now what
happens as P moves around right if you
imagine P just shifting left and right
the saddle piece right moves this way if
P goes up and down I'm moving the the
ring up and down and at most of those
points I'm going to get two points in
the inverse image sometimes they'll get
four sometimes they'll get just one
depending if it's right on the edge but
in any case what you can convince
yourself off is that we recover the
space that we started with using this
procedure okay that's great that says
that we don't have to lose information
so this topological summary doesn't have
to lose information we can recover the
space itself so with a rich set of
functions lenses we recover the original
space with this procedure well I mean
that's kind of a non-starter the
original problem was that the original
space is too complicated to understand
there's too much going on so that
doesn't doesn't really get us anywhere
but it does say we can select the
functions to tune to the signal we want
to to
into the conversation we want we can so
by selecting the functions we choose
what information to get rid of and what
information we want to keep okay so here
we are again for the second time this is
what a Asti does we put these summaries
by choosing the functions we choose what
we're summarizing and we can keep as
much information as we want or we can
eliminate as much information as we want
okay well that's what we do modulo some
details so why is this useful
one of the most common tasks that we do
at a Asti with our data analysis is that
we look for localizations of some
quantity of interest so if you're
looking at online transactions you're
looking for the transactions that are
fraudulent if you're looking at gene
expression data you're looking for the
people who have cancer right so we don't
will we're interested in certain
subpopulations or certain subsets of our
data which is sort of what I put under
the word localization so this is this is
what we're looking for is we're looking
to understand how do we what is the test
what are the you know genetic tests for
this kind of cancer or whether we should
treat this patient with this kind of
drug or whether we should flag this
transaction is fraudulent okay so here's
our summary again so here's one kind of
localization those red points up there
those are the people who are committing
fraud in our data set or those are the
people who who have cancer well what
happens to them under F
well they all end up over there right on
that little piece of the of the Y branch
so you can imagine if this is you know
if this is gene expression data I have
the the original space has thousands of
dimensions but my summary has only right
it's just it's just this Y it just has
really one dimension almost everywhere
and I can just look at it now and I can
see where those cancer patients are
where those fraudulent transactions are
and that gives me the ability to I you
know I know now where to go look at my
data to find the things that interested
in well this year is a particularly easy
kind of localization maybe I'm trying to
distinguish two classes of objects right
red and blue well this is a little bit
harder because over here now we have
purple right with F red and blue get
mixed and I can't separate them out
using using F as a lens well luckily we
have two lenses here I can use G so this
is some some problems like here so some
problems are easy the finding the red
almost any continuous function is going
to localize that red for you in the
output right you have to sort of cook up
some very strange function that that's
going to spread that red all over the
place almost all the functions so
finding that kind of maybe it's like a
classical clustering problem that's just
kind of you know a compact set in your
data that's of interest to you and maybe
there's lots of other techniques you can
use to find it as well and for us I'm
just saying yeah we can do that too and
it's not hard but there are other
problems they can easy that require
maybe a more refined choice of a lens
okay so here's where things get
interesting what if the the things that
you're looking for are themselves
themselves have some complex geometry
inside of your data set
so here my complex geometry is this just
smeared out set of points right they
it's not in a nice small ball region of
the data set it's spread along some
dimension it has some some shape in the
data well F says it's kind of almost
everywhere so F isn't particularly
useful for finding its localization but
again G G is very useful it says oh all
that stuff all that complicated geometry
that it might have it gets summarized
into it all lives right here in your
data set yes just like standard manifold
learning located in everybody's rising
math oh so okay so good question so one
is uh which I tried to mention earlier
that the real real data is never has any
kind of manifold structure so I've drawn
manifold but like forget it
there is no local manifold in like real
big data sets so so that's point one so
I so map can sometimes do this and
sometimes not so I'll show you later how
we can use ISO map as part of our system
and in fact that's something that that
we we do so for us ISO map becomes just
another lens another function so ISO map
all those techniques those kind of
dimensionality reduction techniques kind
of that's part of the framework part of
this talk they all will fit in here as
lenses so our PCA will fit in as a lens
and that's something that's that I'll
describe a little bit later the thing
that you lose when you look at ISO map
so is you don't understand right the
dimensions that you've lost right you
sort of how they've been pressed down
into that representation you don't know
if it like if they just
like with ISO map it would be like
projecting just to the line but
forgetting about the fact that the legs
are separated right if I did an ISO map
a one-dimensional ISO map of this pair
of pants is going to just go that's
unfortunate
it's just going to go it's just going to
be the line right but the point is that
the data as I've see as I drew it I drew
it as two-dimensional but you're
supposed to think of it as a million
dimensional whatever right
a thousand dimension you can't write
doing a thousand dimensional ISO map
defeats the purpose of doing ISO map to
some degree right so so one way you're
thinking about this is that we share
some things in common with a tool like
ISO map or MDS or his knee or something
like that except we we remember
something about the fibers of that map
so that's another way of saying of
thinking about this that remembering
that why is remembering the fibers okay
so lenses inform us on where to look in
the space for phenomena we're interested
in for easy localization problems many
different lenses will work and we see
that a lot sort of no matter what you
try you'll see the localization for hard
problems which hard
I mean geometrically distributed in the
space localizations we have to be more
careful about what lens is so we'll have
to do some work to figure out what
lenses are appropriate but even then we
can get incremental knowledge about the
problem from even a poorly chosen lens
and by incremental knowledge I mean if
we go back here right even this bad lens
I'm able to eliminate that arm as as a
place for the green the green points so
I get some
mental knowledge from even from bad
lenses okay so this is our math world
and now I want to show you how to take
this and translate it into data world so
we're going to move from this world of
nice smooth manifolds continuous
functions into a data-driven analysis so
the first thing we want to do is replace
points in the range with open intervals
well in the data world no matter how big
your data is you always have a finite
number of points which says that for a
randomly chosen point in the range its
inverse images empty right and then when
I try and do this sort of just ranging
over those inverse images drawing points
and connecting them I have no way to
connect them because I get a point and
then I get mostly a bunch of empty
inverse images and I get a point maybe I
get two points right
so I fatten up those points into open
sets so I get take an open covering of
the range of the function
now I again take inverse images of those
open sets and I'm going to also continue
with I'm going to take connected
components of the inverse image I'm
going to draw a dot but now this dot
right represents a lot of points so I
drew a big guy I do that so that's the
inverse image of u1 it's just this kind
of cylindrical piece at the bottom it's
one connected component it gets one dot
u two it's again still one piece it
starts up the legs but it's just one
piece and I get another dot use three
now I have two cylinders in the inverse
image so I get two dots and I'm going to
connect nodes when they're inverse
images intersect so u1 in you to have a
intersection so I connect them and u2
and you know right you three have an
intersection and u2 and left you three
have an intersection but you
left and right you three have no
intersection so the output is now a
graph so the output before for a single
lens was a curve now the output is going
to be graph hold one relation what do
they know
um do upper car officers fewer okay
that's right so well in this case let's
you know if we want to get technical in
this case it's a continuum I've got the
same number of points in all the pieces
that's right
so whoop what you say is a good
suggestion
it's something we could do and it's
something we do do in our software one
of the options that you have in the
software is the size the the points by
the number of data points they contain
but you may want to size them by
something else right for some other
visual effect so I don't want to set
that as like part of the core algorithm
okay so as part of this construction
though I've introduced some more
parameters so before it was sort of a
unique right you give me a data set you
give me a function then those are this
unique output right data set function
does the unique curve according to the
procedure now because the right there's
a question about how many open sets are
you going to take how big are they
whether it's the overlap so I've there's
some parameters unfortunately they come
into the construction so the resolution
is the number of open sets that we have
in the range or the size of the number
if you're thinking of just the
one-dimensional set really the size
maybe of the open sets and the gain is
the amount of overlap they have between
between their neighbors so roughly
speaking the resolution controls the
number of nodes in your output the
number of nodes in your graph and also
the size of geometric feature that you
can pick out
with the procedure while the gain
controls the number of edges in the
graph and also the tightness of the
graph it's a little bit more complicated
to go into kind of technical detail on
on tightness but just resolution is
pretty straightforward to look at so if
I took four open stats instead of three
open sets right well I actually
basically get the same thing except with
just an extra node now inserted that's
because for this lens direction that
that Y right is already the maximal
information that I can really extract
right I already have if you think of it
as a resolution goes to infinity I
should approach the the curve version
right the the line the the Y that's a
line right and with three sets I already
had the Y so I'm not no matter how high
the resolution goes I don't really pick
up anything warm in this case well if I
drop the resolution the two I lose the
topology so the the minimal amount of
information you can recover is just the
the set of function values that that you
have and that's just in this case
represented by a line and that is
actually in a lot of problems enough for
us for a lot of problems we we look at
at a SD even getting just the line or
some people like to call it the worm
it's enough to to solve a problem for
instance if you imagine sort of a if I'm
looking for you know something in the
upper half of my pair of pants they
would all end up in the upper node and
now I know where to go look right so
even the minimal information recovered
is itself useful and interesting in a
lot of cases okay so that was step one
was to look at these open sets coverings
of the range now
connected component if I have data
points right they're all sort of by
themselves the notion of connected
component doesn't make sense so I want
to replace connected component with
something that's going to work in the
data world and so the way I do that is
I'm going to cluster within the inverse
image of an open set
so clustering is data pie not so before
we connected the nodes when they're
inverse image open sets intersected now
we've gone through this clustering and
we're going to connect clusters or nodes
when they share points in common so
there's the these inverse images they
have this band of overlap right and
though there's some points say in that
overlap when I cluster the bottom set
I'm going to those points go to one set
of clusters the top here I'll just stop
trying to explain it and I'll show it to
you because I have a nice illustration
pictures worth a thousand words and I
was heading to five hundred okay so
here's our data world where we have
points so I take this u1 I look at its
inverse image and I do clustering some
clustering algorithm whatever you want
I'm not not particular and I'm saying
that I get two clusters in that inverse
image I go to u2 which is this set I
cluster I got two clusters now there are
points that are in both u1 and u2 those
points go to some clusters in the bottom
set and they go to some clusters in the
top set and I'll just connect those
clusters which I'm saying you know I
didn't actually this isn't like a real
problem I have no idea where the
clustering would send those points but
I'm saying that this is what happens
okay so now I just continue this process
so remember those are now clusters of
data points edges represent shared
points between the clusters and we just
keep going up and we just do this
to the end now I give you this the
preview so that's now we get this more
complicated graph as an output but it
still contains the same essential
information as before which was this Y
structure that the lens was picking out
of the data okay so that's it
that's the full algorithm well of course
again modulo some details
I haven't said what clustering we've
used I haven't said this or all kinds of
implementation details right maybe
you're wondering about how we store our
data tables and how we access things to
do this in a big data efficient right so
module all the stuff that would make
this useful that's what we do okay well
again it's not quite what we do well
what about the lenses right the whole
technique relies on these lenses right
where do you get your lenses from these
continuous functions right that's what's
pulling the information out of the data
that's what's creating the summaries so
um we need to find good lenses and lucky
for us we haven't had to do this on our
own so people have been coming up with
lenses for hundreds of years they just
didn't know that they were coming up
with lenses so here's a non-exhaustive
table of lenses so statistics anything
that produces a number for a point is a
legitimate lens so if I think of a point
as being you know a row in a in a data
matrix I can take the mean of the values
in that row the max of the values in
that row right variance ends moments I
can take the density using some kernel
density estimator right the density is a
value at a point right anything that
gives me a value at a point is a lens so
this here is where our framework starts
to come in we take all this existing
data analysis data analysis tools and we
just say ah nice thank you lenses
well lenses also come from geometry one
of the ones is that we use a lot is
centrality which is also a distance from
the center of mass from your data of
your data it's a good way to look for
outliers or anomalous behaviors in your
data and we've just it's not quite
distance from the center of mass because
we work with abstract metric spaces so
the center of mass is will tricky but we
centrality is a good is a proxy for that
if you have a smooth case which you
never do but if you did you could filter
by curvature if you had some notion of
local curvature harmonic cycles so
there's a way you can look for circles
in your data set the so instead of the
image being the real line your image
space can actually be any other
topological space that has an open
covering so you can the lens can go to
circles as well as it can go to line so
like like we said here so we already
mentioned I put I so map MDS Disney
these are dimensionality reduction
techniques so what do I mean when I say
that's a lens well let's you get
coordinates let's say you do a two
dimensional reduction right to the the
plane you have two coordinates each
coordinate right is a lens in in our
view you could do something like an auto
encoder so this year now this is a
different kind of lens so I really like
these other lenses I'm not trying to
bash neural networks or anything like
that
but I really like these other lenses
because they have intrinsic meaning
outside of the problem that you're
looking at and that means that they're
so that they're not really subject to
overfitting because they don't fit the
data this of the data fits them right I
mean this right that we calculate the
mean you just do it has nothing to do
you don't fit the beam right you just
calculate it so if you're going to use a
function that you fit to the data in
some way
uh you have to be more careful right
overfitting right there's a whole you
know literature and and and Korea was
made out of understanding that issue you
can also look at something like distance
from a hyperplane and an SVM that's a
nice function it gives a real value for
point a very good one for us as a use
case is some kind of error information
about your machine learning system
system because we can very quickly look
for systematic error systematic
deviations within the system and then
the other sort of the other areas domain
knowledge or data-driven lenses right so
this you can just think of this as any
column in your data set is a legitimate
lens lens to use because it's just a
column just has a point right has a
value for every row that's exactly what
a lens is so you can either use lenses
that you you you use columns that used
in the analysis or maybe even more
interestingly you use columns that you
didn't use in the analysis so my example
there is like you're looking at you know
demographic information you could use
age as a as a lens say or you know if
you're looking at something that
happened in history news dates as a lens
okay so we still have I still promised
you a discussion of insight and meaning
so I've showed you the summary but
where's the inside right was that what
does it mean to get meaning from the
data okay so I claim that these lenses
actually sort of generate insights for
you or they generate understanding of
the data in a fundamental way so here we
have their complex data now I've I've
blocked it out so that you can't see it
right but we have our function f our
lens and we have our summary a favorite
summary which is the Y so let's say F is
Gaussian density so I'm filtering the
data by
by debt as a kernel density estimator
and let's say this is low densities at
the bottom and high densities at the top
what is this summary tell me the summary
says my data is bimodal at the height is
too high dense regions and there's a you
know a low dense region in between the
two so if this were if my data were like
say cancer patients this would say I
have two types of cancer right so the
units on the lens
give me some interpretation of the
output allowed me to decide to make it
an insight get new sort of knowledge for
my data let's say F is centrality and
here I have my core is the bottom of the
Y and then I have two flares going out
if this were cancer again it would say
you really have two populations of
cancer right there's sort of two
different ways of being out there and
having cancer you don't maybe it's
breast cancer but there are two kinds of
breast cancer right but they're rare
because they're far away from the
central core if F is mean right let's
just say you know I have sensors of some
sort this would say that when the
sensors are high there are two different
ways that they're high right so the
units on the lens give interpret
interpret ility and meaning to the
topological summary so we learn
something we don't just produce a
summary that we say feed into it's not
really a black box system that just
produces some kind of classification
result for us we actually learn
something about our data you know
something in our guts about our data
some understanding of our data that we
didn't have before from the units of the
lens and from the geometry that we see
in the output yes so this collection of
lenses which you can apply to a set of
data to produce effectively one set of
data for each point and reach the lens
selection what if you take the vector of
all of the lens
and then right through the system again
what do you get you get a way of looking
at what the relative advantages of each
lens are against the particular dataset
um so I have a couple of answers to
question one I filed a bug request to do
exactly that at our system is I'd like
the ability to essentially re embed the
space via you know all of the lenses so
I think that that's something that's
potentially useful it's not something
we've done a lot with so that's like one
wedding answer to your question the
other one is sort of I don't think you
directly get a measure of the quality of
the lens I mean you can look at them all
individually but there's a you know you
really just you're left with the feature
selection problem you know and there's
lots of ways of doing feature selection
on data so I don't think there's a it's
not like a freebie if you just do all of
them then you can like you still have
the feature selection problem to do on
that set of of outputs look Apollo to
you that's right
given lens are given yes absolutely
right yeah from that perspective the
system can help a lot with feature
selection yes
how's everyone doing okay another way of
thinking about lenses which i think is
useful specifically for the lenses you
want to construct yourself like a data
lens is that the lens is a kind of
geometric query of the data so let me
give two examples here these are
entirely concocted examples so let's say
you want to study heart disease so you
have a bunch of you know hearts and you
make all kinds of measurements on them
the the size of various ventricles and
and arteries and you know the muscle
mass and right you get all this
information about the hearts and so you
have this big data set so one thing you
could do is you could just you know
analyze sort of globally analyze die
globally cluster other different kinds
of heart disease right or you could take
a lens like say age and if you use the
aegis lens you'll spread out your data
set over that age and then you cluster
above right above every age your
clustering independently and so you're
saying you know how does heart disease
express itself as a function of age
right so it's a it's a way of querying
your data and it's a geometric query of
the data and the the stratification you
don't have to say I'm going to look at
people of this age in that age because
of this way of binning and overlapping
you get a kind of continuous
understanding of how the age of how the
heart disease varies with age so there's
a geometric way of querying your data
and understanding how does it vary with
respect to my lens with respect to the
output of my lens and another example so
this is something I worked on which is
heavy machinery and a bunch of embedded
sensors
I used mean invariance of the sensor
output with the sliding windows as a
lens to look for operating regimes that
could leave to failure and so
is a collection of 250 sensors so the
data is 250 dimensional and I normalized
them to make sensors comparable because
they were measuring different things and
what I found was with with this query
was that there were two different there
was a high mean high variance failure
and there was a high mean low variance
failure region and which were actually
not quite at the highest mean they were
sort of both kind of a little bit way
away from the highest meet for the
failure for these machines so this sort
of though that the analysis was
constructed as a kind of query against
the data right because of the sensors
and I had some idea that mean and
variance of of temperature measurements
could be something I will also have a
mechanism take in the heart disease case
and sort of inverting it and do the
stratification by disease type or some
indicator of the disease to look for
clusters of me that's right so that's
something we do a lot is so there's an
aspect here and when I when I get to the
live demo I can show that to you where
we we sort of color right networks by
functions that weren't used as lenses
and that weren't used as part of the
analysis and if you get if that function
varies in a nice way across that network
this is that you've sort of it has good
the network has sort of good predictive
powers or tells you something about that
function and and I mean that's so it's a
function that wasn't used in any way in
the analysis and so the way that's
reflected in our software is via
coloring so coloring is just a proxy for
function values on the graph so yeah and
so that's something we look for a lot is
we want to say you know could you
predict age from looking at someone's
heart right so you would build the
network out of all the heart you know
the the heart measurements and then you
would color by age and if it kind of go
you have sort of young and old and they
sort of you get this nice smooth
variation and says yes the the heart
information is a good predictor of age
and then you can reverse that process by
placing points into the network
okay so generalizations and extensions
so the way I've described it is really
not so the technique exists in in much
greater generality than how we've been
discussing it and describing it so one
metrics we don't need a metric at all so
just the notion of similarity will do or
maybe if you just have some way of
clustering the data without any other
notion you can just use use that so we
don't really need a metric so lenses
lenses don't need to be continuous so I
said before just think of a continuous
function lenses don't need to be
continuous I don't want to say exactly
what they need to be what they need to
be is sensible meaning they should have
some meaning for the data set that
you're looking at but we don't have to
define exactly what that means and using
lenses that are discontinuous meaning
you know that I'll say they take values
in a finite number of category you know
categorical information is itself very
useful and something we do a lot so
lenses don't need to be continuous just
sensible so and I don't want to define
sensible it means well sensible don't
take a random function right have it
have meaning for your data so we saw
that in the exercise but I just wanted
to stress it you can use if you use one
lens your output is a one dimensional
object but you can use multiple lenses
and your outputs will will sort of have
higher dimensionality and and we do that
all the time as well you can map spaces
other than R so all we needed we're
using the lens to kind of slice up our
data in a certain way with these inverse
images of opening sets so you can map to
any topological space that has a open
covering created in some way and use the
inverse images and that works fine in
the system there's nothing we used it's
special about R and in fact we don't
even really need lenses at all all we
need is an open cover of the space all
right so that's like the topology when
you know if you want to say well where's
the topology well topology open cover I
all we need our open covers so the data
the data the input space can be anything
with a topology so we work a lot with
row-column data it's just tabular data
rows of the points columns of the
feature but any any type of anything
with a topology on it can work and in
particular I just want to say that
graphs are perfectly legitimate the
input a graph into the process into this
machine the thing that you'll get out at
the other end will be potentially
another graph that has this sort of
completely reshuffled and reorganize the
graph that you're starting with right so
it's a it's a comp it's a transformation
from graph to graph but it's a very
complicated one that that you can do and
then finally that so I've been saying
that the output is a graph really the
output is an abstraction social complex
and I've totally sort of just swept that
under the rug sort of how the higher
dimensional simplices arrive where they
come from in this picture and and I'd
rather not get into that but but the
actual output is an abstract simplicial
complex with higher dimensional
simplices so you can just define i can
take you know three chairs and I just
say one open set is those two one open
set is those two now we're good we have
a topology on this those three chairs so
there's no metric I don't need a metric
it's a finite set I just say group those
like this group those like that
it's ontology remember you need to over
the sense of no consent so we actually
don't and really have to care about so
if you want to run through the math
right of like open sets and you create
the nerve of the covering that's sort of
the world that that we're talking in
then you know you have to follow these
kind of technical technicalities but in
the world that we work in like whether
like there is no right open set well we
have data points we have finite sets
like what like it just doesn't matter
and
and the kind of details aren't important
for for the big for the data side of the
picture they're important though I mean
these kind of details are kind of the
motivation for the technique thinking
about nerves of coverings and check
complexes and all these things motivate
the technique and it tell us where to
look and how to frame what we're doing
but in the actual sort of running
through the details in the finite set
data world it's sort of not it's not an
important quality okay so I work at a
yachty it's a software company and when
you put new software that does this for
you
so I wanted to show you our software
okay
so this here these are this is one data
set and these are four different outputs
using different lenses and metrics of
that one data set so I'm just going to
focus on this one for a moment okay
so this here is a small data set so
there's 272 points and it's a almost
1,500 1,600 dimensional 15 it's 15 sorry
15:53 its 1550 three dimensions so this
here falls into what I would call the
complex data right there's not it's not
big data because there's a lot of points
it's gene expression data for breast
cancer patients so it's complex because
there's when you're looking at the
expression of a gene right they're tied
to each other they related to each other
and complicated ways that you maybe
can't model from first principles and
they're also you know this there's a lot
going on to the data that has nothing to
do with breast cancer right we want in
this particular study we want to know
about breast cancer again this is the
sort of complex data problem but there's
you know there's regular things just
having to do with normal cellular
function in the gene expression data
there's nothing to do with breast cancer
so you want to make have a summary that
that you know gets to the issue the
issue that you're interested in okay so
this here
um this is our network so each node
contains multiple patients right the the
columns are gene expression columns in
the network and I have a Y right it's
not a coincidence that my whole my whole
presentation was like focused on around
the Y so in an actual data set I'm
showing you we get that nice Y so metric
is correlation so I'm looking at
correlation between the columns as the
metric sorry between the rows and my
metric is centrality which is this
distance from the center of mass and the
way you should read this a dataset let
me just actually the way you should read
this data set is that the lo these are
points with low centrality so those are
points at the core of the data and as
you go out moving away from the core at
some point there are sort of two
different ways of getting of being
anomalous in this data set of being far
out from from the core so when I look at
this data set if I just put this in and
this comes up immediately the geometry
starts giving me questions to ask and in
this case the obvious question is well
what's going on at the edge why are
these two groups at the edge so what I
can do is I can make two groups which
I've already done offline I wasn't sure
if I had a was going to new net access
so we this all the processing is done on
our server so so I actually sort of this
is like a semi live analysis because
I've actually already done everything
all right so I apologize for that so I
made two groups and I've titled them
something which you should ignore but I
just you should think I had Group one
and group two and what I can do is I can
take those two points now I want to run
a statistical explain on on those two
groups
and what that does is that so the
geometry guides my question but then I
want to say well statistically how are
these two groups of people different so
we have stuff built into the software
which runs statistics on on the two the
two groups that I made and then it tells
me how they're different and I can just
sort by that and one of the ways they're
different is in so these are genes these
are the names of genes they're as
meaningless to me as they probably are
to you except that I happen to know
where the story ends if if I were
actually doing the analysis I would be
you know a genetic expert and and these
names would mean something to me
but esr1 is a gene that's that's linked
to breast cancer and it's one of the big
distinguishing factors between these two
groups so I had these two the the
geometry right started me sort of my
analysis and now I have a statistical
distinction between two subpopulations
of patients all right so I've sort of
moved from the geometric world to the
statistical world and what I'm going to
go do is I'm going to just color the
network by esr1 so this is what we were
talking about before which is this I'm
just taking a function I'm just coloring
by the function so you're cool values
blue would be low values of the function
and high values would be red I see
immediately that there are two the
distinguishing yes are one which was a
distinguishing factor between these and
I see that this is a really good right
it's high on one and low low on the
other so I also have a column that
wasn't used in using the analysis which
is I know clinical information about
these patients which in this case is
whether they died or not and what I can
see is so this these are the patients
who have died this flare here consists
entirely of surviving patients so I have
a subpopulation of breast cancer
patients right that fit into the certain
profile the certain gene profile that
are going to survive
according to the study and this is sort
of verified independently of us by lots
of people as well I'm just showing you
how we would do it in in this system so
that's sort of how an analysis sort of
typically runs for us is we with sort of
geometry guided analysis and we get
insights from from our from our data
using the geometry and then we verify it
with some traditional statistics for
group differentiation okay so that's how
our software looks and it does lots of
nice nice things I wanted to actually
show you this plot here as well this one
up here so this here is using PCA as a
lens so one thing you might hope for
which is sort of a very traditional you
know standard technique for data
analysis is that you could see these two
flares easily in the PCA plot and in
fact you can and that's sort of the the
power of having different lenses at your
disposal and so what happens with PCA is
you you're finding a linear subspace
that sort of captures the maximal spread
of your data and projecting onto it
right but stuff can happen in out the
projected dimensions and just to
highlight that if you look at where one
of these flares is it's kind of all over
an edge in the PCA and in fact it's sort
of some of the pieces that that flare
lives in aren't even connected or really
near each other the PCA plot and
similarly we see the same thing with the
other one so having those lenses having
other lenses really is you know it is an
improvement over you you want a big
selection of lenses and they really do
put it pull out in different information
and I'll also say that this summary here
this y summary right it kind of gets
right to the core of a question right it
gets right at that the the low esr1 high
survival group it's sort of
it summarizes out all the irrelevant
information it just gives you exactly
what you what you're looking for and
that's the that's what we're looking for
with a good land selection should is
that kind of thing
PCA now there's a lot of things going on
in this PCA summary here you can see
there's these different clusters and
there's all kinds of other questions you
can ask about why are those clustering
the way they are but it's a more
complicated picture and honestly I I
don't actually know what's going on with
those clusters okay so finally I just
wanted to show you a couple more use
cases so this here is a online fraud so
this here is from a company that does
like on you know fraud for large online
retailers if it transactions fraudulent
they have all kinds of information about
your browser about your account history
about you know where you're accessing
from your IP addresses sort of the data
is very rich it has a lot of different
kinds of data and their right
information geospatial information a
browser version information right it's
sort of a very heterogeneous data set
and this so it has you can see here it
has almost seven hundred thousand points
and a thousand something plus dimensions
and where I've colored it right now is
by the Frog store score of the company
that that did produce this data so they
over there internal model that they use
and this year is colored by that model
with red being more more fraudulent so
the topology kind of says that their
model isn't too bad in the sense that we
agreed their model is this nice kind of
rainbow function across the topology
which says that works sort of in
agreement in a very coarse sense with
what their model says and also we've
said that we've split off right there's
these two pieces that have split apart
and we have a high very risky group and
then kind of a mixed group so again what
kind of
the geometry is reflecting something now
they built their model that using any
topology they built it it's a
complicated stuff hand built decision
tree kind of model but it says you know
on first glance we're saying they did a
pretty good job
now there's chargeback information in
the data set so chargeback information
is ground truth for fraud in the sense
that this is when someone says though is
fraud but you didn't catch it right so
these are this is the error like the
ground truth error in the data set and
what we can see is very quickly we're
looking for systematic errors so other
kinds of frauds that they're missing
so some kinds of frauds like this one
everything is a sporadic cases of fraud
no pattern and maybe that one is is like
that but we see how the tips here there
are these high charge back regions of
fraud that the company was missing so
just like we did with the breast scam so
we can run statistical explains what's
going on in the points and we see that
those people are spending a lot of time
on the page on the check out page they
have Flash disabled they have no
JavaScript so this was actually a
surprise for the people who hand-built
the models because usually the fraud
that comes with no JavaScript and no
flash comes from bots because they want
to be fast and they don't spend a lot of
time on the page so when they try to
sort of pre conceive of sort of their
fraud decision models this was just
something they hadn't really considered
but it's something that so that that
systematic errors pops up immediately in
our analysis as and we can identify it
and they went after the fact and they
ended up thinking that they came back to
us and they said that they thought that
this was spousal fraud meaning you use
it you're spending a lot of time on that
check out page because
you using your spouse's credit card sort
of covertly somehow that's what they
told us I don't understand the
JavaScript in the the how that fits into
the spousal forearm picture that's what
they told us okay so this year is
another data set this year is
acceleration information from mobile
phones so this was part of a casual
competition and the question is can you
identify the Parkinson's patients
all right the people so there's this um
there are called uh no there are people
whatever control so our controls and
people with Parkinson's at the data set
sorry I totally blanked there and the
question is can you separate out using
the accelerometer who has Parkinson's
and who doesn't and here we have the red
are all the controls and then the blue
are the patients with parkinson's and
actually the the dominant signal didn't
come from high-frequency tremors the the
signal that we're picking up here has to
do with low frequency handling of the
phone which was a really big surprise to
everyone and I think it's just sort of a
it's so fascinating how again the
topologies kind of pops out this
distinction now here this says that we
have two populations of Parkinson's
patients and there's no we have no
explanation for that and like we can't
say oh this is Parkinson's a and
Parkinson's B we're saying those two
groups based on the phone accelerometer
but we don't have like a you know a
biological understanding of that and and
I don't know if yes the response
function for late cell robber because
they may be the high frequency responses
they're not filtered out that's a good
point I didn't actually do this analysis
so I don't really know what what was
done or how sensitive the phones are
could get the Apple versus the Android
phones yeah these are all Android phones
that were handed out by the so they were
given out by the people doing the study
so that there's like a ground truth in
the phone that was only one person you
don't know that's right you know this so
I actually so that I looked at this data
set so before so I have a little story
with this data set before I was I got I
went to work at I oz day I was on kaggle
you know I was looking at the the data
competitions and I looked at this data
set I was like that's ridiculous because
it's like it's like okay it's like 100
gigabytes first of you know time series
information for a 150 people or
something like that or no first 15
people 15 so it's 150 points here
because of the slicing of the time
intervals for 15 people you know
gigabytes of information I was like this
competition is a waste of time and when
I went to today I see and I was talking
with someone what are the data
scientists they're sort of it was after
I'd been hired but there was like a get
to know you know whatever a pre work
start get to know you thing I was
talking with the data science who did
the analysis Damir and he started asking
me about this competition I was like
that thing is ridiculous
nobody nobody's ever gonna solve that
though it's not going to happen and then
he's like and there there we have it he
he had done it and I think I personally
find it really surprised I mean like I
said I thought that there is no way
anybody is going to do anything useful
with this data set and there we have it
so for me that that right because it
didn't meet my expectations that was
really surprising okay so the last one
emergency room triage model so this here
is an emergency room looking at this a
checklist of sort of things that you
fill out for like how how much how sick
a person is and then there's a model
that says how likely they are to die and
then you know you serve people
appropriately relative to the model so
this at the top is the
the prediction of the model and then on
the bottom is the actual data and you
notice that there's this right away you
see that there's a systematic error
right up top there of people who the
model thought would survive and who were
actually dying and and that we were able
to again very quickly identified as kind
of systemic or another way of saying
systemic linking it back to the talk
earlier is the localization something's
localized in the data set and we were
able to link back this localization
actually to certain forms certain fields
not being filled out on the intake form
so so very quickly being able to
identify that kind of systematic error
and I guess can save lives so okay
that's it
thank you for having me
you